all right let's let's jump in i got a
bunch of questions okay
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've written produced or
directed what's the first thing you want
them watching and why
wow see if you come you come straight in
hard
with the good stuff i really missed you
um i haven't seen you in a long time um
feels like a long time um
gosh
i mean obviously i want to say the 355
because i'm promoting that movie right
now but i think the movie that most
expresses
me
as a person
um
i have a lot of answers for this i'm
going to give you two answers okay
the way that most expresses me as a
person is x-men days of future past
um and the reason for that is
um
uh i love comic books as you know i love
the x-men as you know i grew up loving
those books um
uh it was in many ways the most complex
in every way the most complex script to
write i've ever written because the time
travel and all of the the time paradoxes
and all of that
um
and also it then this is the part that
might be surprising and maybe we've
spoken about this before it was the most
personal movie i've ever written
it was um a time in my life i just got
divorced um
where
what professor xavier was going through
in that movie a man who needed to find
hope again
was what i was going through as a man
who needed to find hope again and
hope is something that's really
important and i think plays through a
lot of my films and a lot of my work um
the importance of it and the value of it
um
and the power of it
uh and ultimately days of future past is
about the power of hope and so i would
say that film thematically most
expresses
me
um
uh the other answer i guess i would give
you
is mr mrs smith
because um i think people see a lot of
my work and maybe deadpool expresses
this but they they
they perhaps think of me as a more
serious human being than i actually am
um and i'm a fun playful silly guy as
you know um as a friend and
uh i think mr mrs smith has a tone
um you know i wrote it when i was really
young i was in film school and i just
was
i kind of wrote it really free
um and it and it you know it's a long
time ago and i've evolved since then and
i have four kids since then and the
world has changed but um there is a
playfulness to that film and a sort of
friskiness to that film that i think um
is also
me i'm not telling you my what i think
or what the best films i've ever worked
on you know i think some people would
argue that martian's the best film i've
ever worked on or logan
but those are the films i think best
express me
sure and i think those uh look there's
no right answer here it's just you know
um
what what do you think of all the films
you've worked on which went through the
most changes in the editing room and why
of all the films i worked on the film
that went through the most changes in
the editing room
um
honestly is probably fantastic for i was
i was just going to ask you and was it
fantastic for yeah i think it was
fantastic for because we really
struggled with the um the tone of that
film um
and
uh
and so i think finding you know one of
the things you do in the edit room other
than obviously just put the movie
together and hope that for the best
is
um when the tone is inconsistent
um
for various reasons and the tones are
often inconsistent mr mr smith went
through a lot of that in the edit and
um
you know a deadpool that went through a
fair amount and yet um the first
deadpool
um uh but but
fantastic four was one where
you know josh trank had a very specific
vision for the film
um i don't know that it was the same
vision as the studio
and i think that the that them butting
it which is not you know this is not um
uh uh
um going to be a surprise to anyone this
is common knowledge um and josh would
say the same thing um
i think that that that struggle between
the two of them um
uh
yielded a lot of work um in the edit um
and back and forth in the edit
uh which you've obviously produced a ton
of movies what film ended up testing
what was your highest test scoring film
uh i'm curious about that or something
like one or two of the highest scoring
test films
deadpool one and two
oh
both of them um i can't remember which
one tested higher i mean what's
interesting about deadpool 1 is um
it it it just
it was one of those films and this is
really a testament to ryan and tim i
mean and to paul and rat the writers um
but to ryan reynolds and tim miller um
is that they they it just kept testing
higher and higher and higher um in post
as they kept doing more and more work
and we did something like only a few
days of reshoots on that film
and the reshoots
shot it up like i don't remember how
many points um but it tested
extraordinarily and i've tested you know
sherlock holmes tested incredibly high
mr mrs smith tested really really high
the martian tested insanely high with
very few
revisions after the first test
um
uh
i'm trying to you know this movie tested
high um 355.
um
but deadpool was one where i can't
remember if it was one or two where it
was like 99 with a 90 definite recommend
it was numbers that the studio had never
seen before
um
it might have been deadpool one
again you know i've been through so many
test screenings because each movie
sometimes can go through ten test
screenings
that uh it's hard for me to remember but
i i know those deadpool movies tested
wildly high in fact the second deadpool
movie tested so high that we then left
los angeles and went to texas to test it
in texas thinking that somehow we were
getting you know
inflated scores in la
um by by cinephiles and we wanted to go
somewhere that was kind of more like a
mall in in the south or middle america
and we went to texas um and it scored i
think even higher um
and i remember we all went to dinner our
plane broke down and and we couldn't
leave and
um and we had a lovely night um in uh
outside of dallas somewhere
uh i also remember that we screened as
part of the collider screening series
deadpool like eight days before it came
out
before i when the film when fox and
everyone was hoping for like a 20
million dollar weekend you know and a
little did anyone know you know that uh
what was going to end up
it was it came out i remember i
remembered really vividly because it was
valentine's day um that weekend that it
came out the first one and um
i had no plans we were making days of
future past at the time i believe or
maybe apocalypse we were making an x-men
movie and
um
and jennifer lawrence was going flying
to new york from montreal for the
weekend i had no plans um
and
no no significant other and um but i was
like i just want to go to new york and
party um for the weekend and
um and i'm gonna be really honest um you
know i think i'm doing the reshoots for
days of future past i can't remember
because if it was winter time it was a
rishi um
in montreal and uh and i remember i i i
partied a little too hard on valentine's
day just just drinking which i i barely
ever do
drinking even i mean um and i i'm just a
clumsy jew and i fell down and i gave
myself a black eye um by falling down
and i had to show up on set on on that
monday or tuesday with a black eye
having gone to new york and been like
yeah i get it i i partied too hard blame
deadpool none of us ever saw this coming
um you know i got smacked in the face by
um you know this historic release
uh yeah it's one of those stories that
um you know uh
it's it's just a great story and the
fact of all the obstacles that movie
went again had to battle to actually get
into a movie theater you know um i i'm
hoping that you know marvel does
something with the character i'm hoping
that there's a deadpool 3 at some point
but you know but who knows um so jumping
into the 355 so uh
um was it uh i'm going to give you a
little [ __ ] for a second but it's also a
loving
loving um so i love the movie sneakers
love
and the macguffin in this is very
similar to sneakers was that like an
homage how did that end up happening
um
uh i love sneakers too i think maybe i'm
a little older than you but it came out
at a time when i was like
it was
to me sneakers is like the grown-up
goonies
it's it's it's somehow like it's a time
where you're like oh i'm a grown-up now
and i like these grown-up movies with
these grown-up actors um
and i really like and i think it's
undervalued um
uh i don't know there was a conscious
homage
um it's something i was aware of
um but i also think it's it's it's
something that
to some extent in one form or another
we've seen mcguffins like it you know
one of the things i love about mcguffins
is that ultimately they don't matter
um i loved what jj did in mission
impossible three where the macguffin is
just the rabbit's foot and you never
know what it is
um it's just the mcguffin uh er you know
the maltese falcon does something really
radical with the notion of um the falcon
and you know um
in that movie
so um
i was more interested in this one we all
were in the characters um and in this
ensemble of of sort of characters coming
together because it's it's very rare in
in
spy movies really rare weirdly rare that
you have ensemble spy movies you have
bond and bourne and kingsman and the
whole list but you you know the last
ensemble spy movie i can think of is
ronin
um
and
which is a movie i really like uh and so
i i was just really interested in these
these characters and jessica was too as
jessica's idea from the beginning these
characters coming together rapidly
female these characters coming together
um
from different countries with different
agendas and having to form a team and
you know you and i both love team
superhero movies um and i've worked on
team superhero movies and this was um a
team spy movie
yeah i'm only giving you [ __ ] about the
macguffin
i
i agree with you the mcguffin really
doesn't matter it could just be a pen
you know it's just what's driving the
the plot forward you know um you got to
film in paris and all over the uk um and
you got to do this all obvious basically
talk a little bit about how you decided
on where where you wanted the film to
take place and also the the one thing
that i i took away from the paris stuff
is you shot in locations that you
typically don't see in movies like the
paris underground on those train tracks
uh can you sort of talk about all that
yeah i mean we we really wanted the
movie to be to be global um both in
terms of the cast and in terms of the
locations um and we shot as many places
as we could um
uh obviously the cast is global we have
german and spanish and um british and
british british african we have american
we have
um chinese so um
you know we started in paris
and it's rare and an
uh privilege especially in a movie that
doesn't have a massive budget um
uh to be able to shoot paris for paris
and we shot in places that i never ever
thought especially with the sort of
preconceptions of paris and the french
they would let us shoot and so yes they
let us shoot in the paris underground
down in the tracks which was scary
because there were real third rails and
places that you could not go where you
would be electrocuted to death
which is not fun to shoot with a big
crew
um and there were certain amounts of
people that were allowed in at different
times and all that and so it was it was
it was very um you know it was done as
safely as possible and luckily obviously
totally safe
um uh but what was really fun was and i
think this might have been our first day
we shot in
they told us the oldest i'm gonna assume
it's at least one of the oldest um
uh arcades like indoor malls um in in
paris and we ran up
diane kruger on a motorcycle and jessica
running and pushing through crowds of
extras um through the arcade and
destroyed stuff in the arcade um
that was really fun we created a rig to
be able to shoot it and be in front of
the back of the um
in this narrow space to be in front and
back of the uh uh of the motorcycle with
with the camera um
and so yeah we shot the streets we shot
on we shot a bridge down in paris and
shot uh
sebastian chasing edgar ramirez
um
and just it's nice being listen man like
it's incredible being in paris you know
um
and then be able to being able to be
there for three four weeks and shoot the
weeks before that prepping was a dream
um and then the rest of it was most of
the uk we shot a little bit in morocco
um we built some of morocco in the uk
uh and um and we and we shot all over
london um
mostly locations even if it was an
interior instead of building it on a
stage we did it as a as a location um
just because
we built into a look into into a
location um you know and
we we liked the idea of being again kind
of down and dirty and gritty and in the
streets um
and feeling like we weren't stage bound
um which can give i think the the
characters or the actors and actresses a
feeling of things being fake
well i mean one of the reasons why the
james bond movies are the james bond
movies is they're filming on location
you can't you know the location is every
anyway it just adds so much realism um
talk a little bit how you work with your
dp tim on the aesthetic of the film how
you wanted it to look i mean i noticed a
lot of handheld camera uh can you sort
of talk about that yeah i mean timorese
jones is a
you know he worked on the early guy
ritchie movies
and he's a big music video director and
commercial uh music video
cinematographer and um and
uh and commercial cinematographer and i
really liked his work because it's so
kinetic
um and that's the word that we kept
using throughout the movie
and um i think it's the aesthetic he
brought to the film and we have handheld
in pretty much
every scene um we have it throughout the
action but we also have it in dialogue
scenes um so that nothing feels too
static and staged um
and too much of like a proscenium like
you're watching a play it just feels
like it's moving the way that life moves
right like when you're in a room with
somebody you're not static ever you and
i are right now sitting in chairs doing
this interview but you know when we get
up from these interviews we're gonna go
to downstairs or outside or whatever um
and we wanted the move the camera to
rove that way in fact there's not even
that much steadicam it's almost entirely
handheld
um and it it it's it's also what's nice
about a handheld is it gives you lots of
surprises because it's it it's inexact
right like nothing's precise
totally precise about the frame when
it's handheld um it's kind of roving
around and finding things and the
corners of frames become surprising um
and not locked off
uh and so and there's a sort of
imbalance to it slightly as well which i
wanted the movie to have so it didn't
feel like it was too
again static um
so yeah
uh uh this is a little bit of a jokey
thing but um so um you have most you
have an all basically an all-women cast
and so you know most spy movies like
bond movies it's all men and you have
the bond girl so how did you decide on
sebastian stan being the bond guy if you
will yeah you know what i mean
yeah we when we joked about sebastian
and edgar ramirez being the bond boys
exactly yeah uh
we chose them because
they're one they're obviously great
actors um two they're great looking guys
the way that you would choose um
a bond
boy
um
uh
but also because they're friends um
sebastian uh became a friend uh with
jess of jessica's and mine from um the
martian
uh they worked together obviously they
were in the crew of of the of the ship
and the martian um and he's a
extraordinary actor and a lovely guy and
i'm a big fan
um
there was no audition we met um for
breakfast in new york um he read the
script he liked it he was in
edgar is a really close friend of
jessica's and then became a really close
friend of mine once we made the movie
he's really close to penelope as well
who we did whom we'd already cast
um
and we sent him the script he liked it
and he was in um again an incredible
actor and
you know um a not bad looking guy
uh
so you know i will say it's funny i do
talk about this movie and i'm like it's
down and dirty and gritty and real and
then it's like and also the spies are
all gorgeous
um you know so there is that element of
it that is uh a movie reality where um
the male and female spies all happen to
be um
you know the most beautiful people in
the world
uh i love talking about the editing room
because it's ultimately where everything
comes together so with this film
specifically did you have a much longer
cut how did it get shaped in the editing
room
i never had a much longer cut
i had a few scenes that we cut so it
wasn't like i went in and trimmed
the hell out of existing scenes it was
more like do we need this scene is it
slowing down the momentum of the movie
and you know the way this movie was put
together and made we really had
unbelievable creative or i had
unbelievable creative freedom um it was
a
essentially an independent movie we sold
the cannes film festival um universal
were our partners in uk and us but it
was
it was um
it was ours and so it wasn't like i was
you know i was given notes but it wasn't
like anything was a dictate uh and i
worked with lee smith who you know well
um and is i you know
arguably one of if not the not not
arguably inarguably one of arguably the
best editor in the world
um it's kind of good
yeah i mean he did pretty good job with
all the chris no movies um he's kind of
good yeah and i think he's won one oscar
he i think because of inception deserves
two he's just like he's just the best
and he's just a great guy um
and we've worked together a few and i
think our third movie together in some
form and
uh he's just so good at like pinpointing
moments
um that could take longer actually that
could breathe um
going in the opposite direction and then
he's really good at being like you don't
need this scene or you think this scene
is ending here but this scene is really
already over
um and i really treat lee the same way i
would treat the actors and actresses
which is a real partner and it's like a
real collaboration and
i'm all too eager to have their ideas be
better than my ideas
well i mean i've always heard about
spielberg it's always the best idea in
the room wins and it's still his name on
the movie yeah yeah exactly i mean
listen the way that and i and i this
this extends to studio notes i know
there's a lot of um you know filmmakers
who hate studio notes or hate you know
test screenings and i'm like these are
all free ideas
these are free ideas that you can do
with what you want and they can spark
better ideas they can be rejected they
can be embraced but who's not going to
take a free idea you know
well i think i think
what the
uh with this movie you had creative
freedom but i think sometimes what
people rebel against and this is just me
speaking is when a filmmaker it's like
their first or second movie doesn't have
as much creative clout and the studio is
saying we're gonna do this yeah and then
you know what i mean yeah but i think
there's a way yes i totally know what
you mean i think there's a way
to be as creative with notes as you are
when you're by yourself facing a blank
page and if you're not and you're shut
down
to notes then you are going to get into
a battle with the studio or with a
partner or with an actor actress but if
you're open
more times than not
if you feel really strongly or
passionately that the note is not right
you will be able to work your way or
talk your way through it more often than
not i'm not saying it always happens
i'm just if you think that there's yeah
i think there's an attitude um
uh an approach
to taking notes that is
creative rather than just you know um
professional
uh what do you actually think for soon
to be fans of the movie what do you
think they actually would be surprised
to learn about the actual making of the
film
you know maybe they'd be surprised to
learn
how much of the stunts the women did
themselves
um just because i think we're used to
movie stars not doing their own stunts
and it was really important for jessica
specifically jessica and diane did the
majority of the stunts in the movie um
to do their own stunts and to do all
their own fighting um
jessica's in that scene where she's in
outside the fish market and she's on
that beam 50 feet above the ground and
jumping onto it onto a shipping
container on a ship that's all jess
um in heels and
so maybe that would be the thing that
would surprise people just because maybe
we're used to
assuming
again especially on a movie like this
assuming
um that there are stunt people and there
were stunned people but that there were
stunned people doing the majority of the
stunts and in fact it was the actors the
actresses
and jessica's obviously a producer on
the movie um at any point was she like
as the producer does my character need
to wear heels in this scene
she had plenty of ideas i mean all the
actresses and actors had ideas um she
never like pulled the producer card um
on me or on anybody else but wasn't
incredibly um involved producer uh so
you know
again this is this was her idea um and
uh and i was really respectful of that
as somebody who's had original ideas
before so like i wanted to honor her
being the originator of the idea um
but yeah no she she didn't she didn't
have notes about the heels um i will say
that there were a few costumes or
outfits that came from her imagination
but that was true for all of the actors
and actresses specifically the um the
cream suit in morocco
um was something that she uh was
passionate about i think until she
realized that linen in a hot environment
is actually not as um as yeah as as good
as as as you think it's gonna be um it
wrinkles pretty easily um and in between
each take takes a lot of time
um but uh but yeah i know she she she's
a pleasure to work with and and she's
like a really really close friend she
our families are friends she really is
one of my closest friends i adore her
and
um and she was great and and she was
great the whole way and really
industrious and her producing partner
kelly carmichael was really involved and
you know we were we were all a team
making this movie and when they say we i
mean myself them and and the actors now
main actors and actresses
uh before i run out of time you produce
i'm going to say a lot of things i'm
going to use it i'm going to use it like
that and so while i have you i do want
to ask you a few other things
first congrats on invasion getting a
second season
uh but because i have such little time i
just want to start with that um what is
the story with the running man and that
remake is that moving forward is that
something that i might be seeing soon
um it is moving forward edgar wright is
attached to co-write and direct the
movie um co-write with michael book call
um and
i sure hope it's something you're seeing
soon um that part's not up to me but um
it's something that they're working on
um
uh i believe you're producing something
with andrew stanton directing um what is
in its uh chairman's spaceman
at searchlight um and we have a great
script
um and andrew is doing a final tinker on
the script and then we'll be going out
to actors okay so it's like the script
is pretty good
it's really good
yeah i heard andrew's pretty good as a
you know director yeah he's really good
at director and you know he's it's
i've been a huge fan of the pixar movies
and he's brought a lot of the pixar
process to the storytelling of the
script and it's extraordinary to watch
because he is a real master of
storytelling
rather than me pin actually by one other
thing for you um that i want to ask
specifically so what's up with
battlestar galactica because i heard
about it for a while and then i know
that there's the movie and i know sam is
working on a series and like how what
exactly what can you tell fans i could
tell fans that um
i'm done with the second draft of the
script
and um we are in the process of um going
out to directors
and the hope is to um attach a director
and
start prepping the movie this year it's
a
magilla humongous film and the prep will
be a very long prep period so i would
imagine even if we attached a director
today it would take six nine months to
prep this movie properly so at the
earliest we'd be shooting at the end of
this year we're probably shooting at the
beginning of next year
um
time will tell who the director is and
then
and then you or someone else will tell
who the director is um
uh in terms of the the the
the situation with sam in the show
um
i can't say too much about it other than
there is synergy
between the two and the two enterprises
and
um constant communication between us
we've become close um and been having a
really good time together um and there
will be
um
uh for lack of a better phrase and it's
an overused phrase a shared universe
i understand i have to i mean listen i
love battlestar galactica and i'm
incredibly excited that you guys are
developing something so for fans of the
series that was on a decade ago or
whatever does it connect to that or is
this like a completely new thing
gosh um
you're asking me a hard question that
i'm not sure i'm allowed to answer um
there is there are connections
but it isn't it is certainly not simply
a continuation
or a remake of
um ron moore's masterpiece
god i'm i'm being given the the wrap-up
signal so i will just say
that uh when you can tell me more i
would love to know more and uh i'm very
excited for that and look man i wish you
nothing but the best and congrats on the
movie and
you know um well you know yeah it's
great to see you i miss you i miss your
black fingernails